2008 in Los Angeles a conversation
between Jeff Bezos founder and CEO of
amazon.com and Chris Anderson
editor-in-chief of Wired magazine among
the topics discussed is kindle Amazon's
new wireless reading device and all the
new innovative things that can do book
Expo America is an annual trade show for
the publishing industry that includes
author events educational panels and
information on soon to be published
books the event is an hour
well I last time I spoke here was eight
years ago and my oldest son is eight
years old I have four kids now eight six
three and three and that's what makes me
such a homebody but I am very glad to be
back let me start out how's that good so
I read you a paragraph here throughout
American history presidential
administrations have undergone
tumultuous periods of war and scandal I
happen to become White House press
secretary at a time when the
administration of george w bush was
going through both and they were
intimately related to each other that
book is sold out almost everywhere
and of course this scott McClellan's
what happened it'll be back in stock at
amazon we think on june 9th and in the
car on the way here i downloaded on to
my kindle and it was there in less than
60 seconds and it's one of the great
things about electronic books is they
don't go out of stock let me show you a
one customer's Kindle purchases this is
just a single customer they bought all
of these things but they also bought all
of these things and I'll make the font a
little smaller because they kept going
maybe I should go to multiple columns
because they kept going and they also
bought all of these things
and they bought all of these things this
customer has bought 1076 Kindle books
and still counting
well three years ago we started working
on Kent a little more than three years
ago now about three and a half years ago
and we really wanted to capture what we
thought was the essential element of the
physical book which is that the book
disappears it disappears in your hands
you aren't thinking about the glue and
the paper and the ink all those things
go away and what remains is the author's
world and it's very hard to make an
electronic device have that very elegant
feature that physical books have
physical books are in roughly the same
form that they have been for 500 years
Gutenberg if reincarnated today would
more or less recognize a physical book
and quit and clearly know what to do
with it he'd be astonished by modern
printing technology to be sure but the
book itself he would recognize that
artifact and probably I suspect be quite
pleased that it had lasted 500 years and
the anything that lasts 500 years is not
easily improved upon and yet that is the
goal that we've set for ourselves so but
the first step in improving upon
something is to try and capture the
essential Nisour the thing why has it
been so loved and so useful for so many
centuries and I do think it's the
ability to disappear and get out of the
way in an electronic device like Kindle
one of the things we knew we had to do
is make it very light so weighs ten
point three ounces if you try to read
for long periods of time with a laptop
or a heavier device you get too much
hand fatigue it's not really convenient
it breaks you out of the flow same thing
with ice strain you need a paper like
display the Kindle uses electronic ink
for those of you you know the first time
you see electronic ink displays you do a
double-take they are completely
like any other kind of computer display
that you've encountered they have to be
readable in the sunlight they have to be
low power consuming this is important
for a couple of reasons one I can't
imagine anything more likely to break
you out of the readers flow then your
device running out of battery power
right in the middle of your reading
session that would be annoying second of
all if devices consume a lot of energy a
lot of battery power they get warm and
that really breaks you out of the flow
too if you've ever sat with a laptop in
your lap for any length of time they
actually make you start to sweat a
little bit they're very uncomfortable
you certainly can't curl up in bed with
one there are other things too very
tactical things the device can't beep at
you we have I had a microwave oven in my
house at one point that when it finished
cooking food it would beep at me once a
minute until I opened the door I
couldn't believe it I call those devices
self-important devices and it's very
important for devices not to be
self-important there's suss to get out
of our way well if you can capture that
essential feature of the book that's
great but you've got to do something
more because books are so good and you
can't out book the book you can't try to
clone the book you have to figure out
some things that you can do with the new
technology that could never be done with
a physical book we've found several of
those things and incorporated them into
Kindle one of them is that you can
there's a big dictionary the paper
version of this dictionary weighs over
eight pounds its resident on Kindle and
you can look up words on the fly very
very easily I have discovered that my
vocabulary is not nearly as good as I
thought it was normally of course you
know I would find a word and I'm too
lazy to get up and go find a dictionary
or go to the web and look up the word on
the web so I will just sort of guess the
meaning of the word from context and I
had it you know was living in a nice
fantasy world work my contextual guesses
were fairly accurate the Kindle has
disabuse me of that notion
it's very nice to be able to look up
words on the fly you can you can make
margin notes underline things on the
Kindle and and write margin notes the
key thing is that those margin notes are
stored on the server side in the cloud
so that as you you know the the problem
with margin notes in a physical book is
that retrieval isn't easy I make margin
notes most of my margin that's actually
under linings and exclamation points and
a few words here and there but I can
rarely go back and find a particular
margin note with Kindle margin notes
because they're stored on the server
side one you can never lose them and two
you can search for your margin notes if
you remember a keyword or in the text
that's related to the margin note you
can search on that and find things you
can change font sizes I read on the
treadmill and it's very nice to be able
to increase the font size on the
treadmill to be able to read but the
Whopper of features that we put into
Kindle that simply cannot be done with a
physical paper book is that you can
think of a book and 60 seconds later
have that book we have Wireless on
Kindle it's a video Wireless which is
the fastest wireless radio in the United
States its 3G it's the same network that
you use for advanced cellphones and we
hide the complexity of the cellular
network and the cellular business
relationship from the customer so when
you buy your Kindle we bundle the
wireless download costs into the cost of
the content so when you spend $9.99 to
buy a book that includes the cost of
wirelessly getting that book to your
Kindle you do your shopping directly
from the store
so the traditional way that you would
think about a device like this is that
you would have to connect it to your
computer you go to your computer by the
ebook that you wanted on your computer
connect your e-reader to the computer
and then you know use a USB cable or
something to move the the book over to
your reader it's not very convenient
with a wireless access that's
it's cellphone and wireless access
that's built in completely hidden
no two-year contracts no monthly data
plan completely hidden all hiding all
that complexity from the customer you
can just go to the store which is
resident on the device search for what
you want browse find what you want push
a button in less than 60 seconds later
that title is there and available for
reading it's not just books we also have
newspapers magazines and blogs that you
can read and those subscriptions are
delivered automatically overnight so
that when you wake up in the morning
your newspapers are already waiting for
you on your Kindle you can also email
yourself personal documents so every
Kindle comes with an email address and
if you have a word doc a manuscript or
something else and you want to read it
you can email it to your Kindle and it's
it'll be there for your reading here's
some feedback we're getting we hope for
good feedback from customers dear mr.
BAE's S & Company this is Gutenberg
cubed I can't tell you what a
frustration it has been for many years
because I travel a lot on business
that's what a frustration it is to be
where my library is not your work on
this project will yield such a personal
and intellectual benefits for me I'm
truly very appreciative we like that one
but and we thought this one this next
one was even better the Kindle is up
there with haagen-dazs and sex
it's brilliant it just feels like the
future beyond that however I marvel at
its design interface and delivery system
congratulations this is Stephen King who
gave us the kindest compliment we could
have received in Entertainment Weekly
reviewing the Kindle for a while I was
very aware that I was looking at a
screen and bopping a button instead of
turning pages then the story simply
swallowed me as the good ones always do
I wasn't thinking about my Kindle
anymore it became about the message
instead of the medium and that's the way
it's supposed to be and that was our the
reason this is the kindest compliment
anyone could give us is because that was
our prime design objective with Kindle
when we set out three and a half
years ago we did we underestimated how
much demand we would have for Kindle
we've sold out in the first day and we
scrambled for five months to get back in
stock I'm pleased to report that Kindle
is in stock after us increasing our
manufacturing capacity it is also just
this past Tuesday now three hundred and
fifty nine dollars we've reduced the
price from $399 we're excited to be able
to do that we want to make this device
as affordable as we can oh.why our
readers excited about Kindle I'm about
to share with you something so obvious
that you may at first be tempted to
dismiss it and I would ask you not to do
so because I think that the reason that
readers are so excited about Kindle is
because readers love to read and
anything that makes reading easier is
very exciting to people the fact that
you can download a book in less than 60
seconds is a big deal for readers you
know it brings it brings the kind of
convenience that BlackBerry users have
gotten accustomed to with regard to
email it brings that kind of convenience
to people who love to read books overall
well done I found that I can indeed lose
myself in the book while reading on my
Kindle I should also compliment you on
the way you streamlined buying books to
enable you even more impulse buying but
I'm not sure that's necessarily a good
thing given the current economic client
climate reading books is so much more
fun with the Kindle I'm getting addicted
quickly to downloading buying books love
the Kindle it's a gateway drug I'm
reading more and buy more books well one
of the things that now that Kindle has
been out for six months we have some
data that we can collect and I can share
with you that after purchasing Kindle
customers continue to purchase the same
number of physical books that they
bought before buying their Kindle but
all together if you take the Kindle
books plus their physical book purchases
their book purchases on Amazon increase
factor of 2.6 something that really I
find very startling is that just six
months in Kindle purchases for this
universe of a hundred and twenty five
thousand titles that we have available
on Kindle Kindle book units are 6% of
Amazon's physical book units and keep in
mind to make sure that that's in the
right context we've been selling
physical books on Amazon now for
fourteen years and in six months we have
6% as many Kendall sales of this
universe of titles as we have physical
sales but we're very excited about that
to have that this early stage well my
two favorite ways to use my Kindle is
number one while drying my hair in the
morning I used to dread the waist in ten
minutes each morning drying my hair but
I so wish I had this problem now now I
look at it as 10 more minutes of me time
that I can spend reading my book
catching the morning news or reading a
new blog and - while cooking dinner for
my family I now have the ability to
multitask and turn a mind-numbing task
into more me time as they stir with one
hand and read with another the Kindle
doesn't turn off or lose my place when I
go to the fridge take a phone call or
help my daughter draw a penguin
beautiful we're going to show a quick
video can somebody go ahead and cue that
video please the point that I realized
that I had had moved from skeptic to
absolute believer in this device was
with my daughter Maddie who's 12 we were
on the plane they hadn't quite shut the
doors well she's got one thing to read
and I went on to Amazon with the Kindle
downloaded a bunch of Meg Cabot books
that Maddie had wanted to read and stuck
them on there it's like having a genie
who you say genie go and get me this
book and they come back in
seconds and the book is there that that
in itself is amazing when I have the
reading time I don't have the books with
me and you know on the flight from from
Beijing to Budapest I'm gonna have a lot
a reading time but I'm not gonna have a
backpack full of books because I can't
carry a backpack full of books around
with me but I can put them all on the
Kindle and that that's where things get
exciting that's that's the point where
the Kindle suddenly as far as I'm
concerned becomes completely worth its
weight in gold
we've been at explain that I realized we
could listen to that again I like it
at launch we had ninety thousand books
on Kindle we've been adding books since
launch six months ago and today we have
125,000 books on Kindle and this
includes you know a hundred roughly a
hundred of the 112 New York Times
bestsellers so it is the books that
people are looking for the vision for
Kindle is we want to have every book
ever printed
in any language in print or out of print
all available in less than 60 seconds
how cool would that be if you could be
anywhere and think of any book in any
language ever in print and be reading it
in less than 60 seconds I think that
would be very cool
now I would like to introduce Carol
Reedy
from Simon & Schuster Carolyn come on up
hello first I'd like to thank Jeff for
having us here today and to commend
Amazon for the vision that they have for
the Kindle as a publisher the idea that
our books could be available to any
reader instantly all the time is an idea
that we can truly embrace as many of you
know Simon and Schuster has been
involved with eBook publishing since its
inception in 1968 most famously for
publishing Stephen King's writing the
bullet in 2000 and yes that publication
was considered a huge success with some
600,000 downloads in two days but it
also highlighted the limitations of
electronic publishing at that time the
clunky first generation devices service
crashing across the country and no one
could keep up with the demand what it
did in fact was lead retailers and
publishers to be concerned about the
consumer experience now almost 10 years
later actually just eight years laters
and after a lot of effort Simon and
Schuster
we have about 4,000 titles available in
eBook that's a healthy number but by no
means close to the majority of our
titles even though we have untold a
reputation is one of the most
enthusiastic publishers of e-books and
the marketplace has as Jeff pointed out
needed more content better hardware and
a better all-around user experience
we're now finally at the tipping point
SNS and most major publishers have
invested heavily in digitizing their
catalogs and building the infrastructure
that will support digital commerce newer
ebook devices like the Kindle with their
improved display and better software
together with a much more user-friendly
consumer buying experience at sites like
Amazon are far better than what was
previously available and most of all
readers can now easily buy ebooks at the
place where they buy books and have a
high-quality reading experience once
they've made that purchase so when
Amazon challenged us to make a huge
portion of our titles available on
Kindle by the end of 2008
Simon is Shuster decided the time was
right and we're happy to partner with
Amazon to do it to make the commitment
and greatly accelerate the pace at which
we're bringing our titles into eBook by
the end of this year we are going to add
five thousand titles to what is already
available on Kindle more than double our
current total we're doing in one year
what it took us ten to previously
achieve while we have been making most
of our front list available in recent
years now we have worked with Amazon to
select all of those books which in paper
and ink have been most popular with
their customers we think that this is
this excellent combination of both
quality and quantity will help give
Kindle readers more of the broad
selection of titles that are proven
bestsellers some back lists like Stephen
Covey's seven Habits of Highly Effective
People they have been demanding for
years combined with the titles currently
available our ebook catalog will now
include books that account for the vast
majority of our sales and we're excited
to hear the news as jeff has pointed out
the Kindle customers are buying two and
a half more times times more books those
kinds of numbers make us feel good about
taking on an initiative like that so
thank you again Jeff for sharing the
stage with us today we look forward to
working with you to keep the momentum
going in growing the e-book marketplace
and in selling lots of more titles to
Kindle customers
I'll just remind you of the vision that
we really want to have every book ever
imprint all immediately available I
think it's an exciting vision I think
it's a great vision for readers we find
we're very Missionary about this vision
that Amazon is very energizing and fun
for those of you who would like to learn
more about this you can visit our booth
there and also feel free to go to
amazon.com slash Kindle publishing where
you know there's a lot of information
about how to get your books in Kindle
format as well as how to get help from
us and getting your books in Killah
format if you'd like us to help so thank
you very much I appreciate it it's very
fun to be here and I think now we're
gonna sit and chat with Chris who I
think is somewhere in the audience
there's Chris come on up thank you
I'm air water to say water delivery so
we have about half an hour to do an
interactive portion of it I guess I
wanted to start pretty much where you've
just left off with your ambition we have
125,000 titles today and last time I
sort of guesstimated there's something
on the order between a four and five
million titles in the Amazon you know a
catalogue more broadly
can you walk through what its gonna take
to get from 125 to your your vision what
what are the processes necessary to
bring more books that aren't on the
Kindle on well there will be some
processes necessary but I think the main
thing is gonna be necessary is
temperament because it's gonna take
patience and relentlessness the you just
can't get something that kind of vision
is very very important to have because
it's you know it sets the stage for the
next 10 years or whatever is the
timeline it takes time to do something
you're literally talking about every
book that's ever been in print think
about what that means you have to figure
out how to you know in many cases solve
the problem of what if the rights are
not clear on that particular book what
if the book sale what if you're afraid
that the sales the the e-book sales will
not be sufficient to justify the
conversion cost
so they're both economic issues and
there are legal issues and basically you
have to just you know slowly but surely
work through all of those things and you
know you get great partners and we've
been very supported by publishers in
this endeavor and we're excited about it
but I do think it's gonna take you know
there are gonna be a myriad of issues
now that the new books will be able to
get those and I think we'll be able to
do that very rapidly but as we go back
you know to this getting further and
further into the long tail something you
guys may know Chris knows a lot about
wrote a book called the long tail kind
of the founding premise of Amazon that
we wanted to have this extensive
selection including the obscure books in
fact when we started Amazon I you know
we had to
Ray's a angel money raised a million
dollars from 22 investors it took 60
meetings and people who the more you
knew about the book industry the less
likely you were to invest in Amazon and
the reason was and but this is 1995 and
so everybody's first question was what's
the internet so I had to sort of explain
that but then but then the reason was
they didn't believe in this idea of
nobody wants to buy this longtail right
and that was really the founding premise
if you go back and look at Amazon's
original business plan the way we were
going to differentiate ourselves is by
making it convenient and easy for people
to find these hard to find books and I
think that that has made the whole
ecosystem much more vibrant anyway I
think it's very exciting and we can do
if we're patient
the same thing with electronic look
suppose it'll be much better because
it'll be so convenient for people when
you look at the universe of books not in
I mean you have I have you done
calculations how many of them you know
are digital but don't have the rights
how many do have the rights but aren't
digital how many don't have a either I
mean what are very few of them are
digital in fact some of the ones that
have been digitized they've been
digitized in a haphazard enough way that
they can't really be ocr'd from that
quality of an image and they really
would have to be done again more
carefully so this you know the just the
practical nuts and bolts issues are you
know if you have if you're a small
publisher and you have a few titles it's
very manageable but if you have you know
tens of thousands of titles in your back
list if you know the numbers start to
add up on the conversion costs and so
people start to get very focused on that
and then if you have issues and then
some titles we just make you may take
longer because maybe the rights are tied
up in estate issues or arguments or what
have you and that's okay I mean there
may it's okay for there to be holes now
that persist over time it's what's
important is the vision and that and
every day in every week and every month
and every year making progress against
that vision in the pursuit of this
glorious thing so when we're sitting
here next next year this time what
number of total titles would would you
be happy with I don't know I mean you
know I probably won't be happy unless we
have 2 X 3 X 20 million but I'm hard to
make happy I'm very grateful I mean you
know I like the the endorsement that
Carolyn is making today I mean this is a
huge effort and a great commitment of
Simon & Schuster to do that it's you
know five thousand titles before the end
of the year more than doubling the you
know I spent 10 years getting to 4,000
and this year they're gonna do five it's
a big deal and that's the kind of you
know effort it's gonna take across big
publishers as well as as well as small
publishers I actually think in some ways
we're seeing you know kind of faster
adoption among smaller publishers and I
think in some ways is because it's it's
a more tractable human scale problem if
you have a handful of titles so so the
number of wouldn't necessarily get the
two or a three or you want to you don't
want I'm just gonna cuz I just honestly
don't know enough we'll find out next
year we'll find out so one of the
there's a couple things I want to pursue
in our in our time together and you are
incredibly fortunate and that you've
seen a period of revolution in the book
industry have caused a period of
revolution in the book industry 9 and
I'd like to know I'd like to get your
thoughts about how does this change the
nature of reading has the change of the
making of writing has it change the
relationship between reader and writer
because let's actually start while we're
on the subject of the Kindle you've
described a couple ways by which the
Kindle can change you know what it can
to change the meaning of a book in the
sense you can have this interactivity to
search it cetera but what about the
actual form of writing a book you know
right for the Kindle I think you can and
I think one of the grand experiments
that we're gonna see play out over time
is that there some changes may occur you
know can you have a never-ending book or
there's you know always a new chapter
being added on to the end of the book
can you have
a book where you know if the book sights
like a population figure of a certain
country can that be magically always
up-to-date can you know maybe we should
go back to the time of Charles Dickens
and have books done serially you know I
think there'll be a lot of experiments
you know it's a well it's not something
we've actually even spent a lot of time
thinking about inside Amazon what we
want to do is create a platform that has
enough flexibility
you know enough tool set that lets
publishers and authors you know surprise
us and surprise readers with their
creativity that's one of the marks of
having a healthy ecosystem is that that
the the tool set and the things you can
do allow for you know even the creators
of the tool set to be surprised I never
expected that tool to be used that way
and so that's what we're trying to do is
to create something that over time will
let I don't think it's gonna change the
heart of long-form narrative I think you
know narrative structure is more about
the human being and less about the tools
you know we are storytelling animals and
we like to you know that we like a
narrative arc and we like even
nonfiction fiction no matter what that's
not gonna change but there may be things
around the edges you know and I
certainly we I'd be startled if you
don't see people experiment with the
return to Charles Dickens kind of idea
well and that experiments already
happening in Asia with cell phone cell
phone serials cell phone comics mangas
etc that's right does that I guess first
question what what have you learned from
the from the mobile reading experience
in Asia and secondly does that in a
sense put the Kindle in competition with
the cell phone down the line of cell
phones become have better screens and
maybe the hardware device yes but not
necessarily the Kindle books so the
Kindle books you know maybe they should
be available on every device you know we
we created Kindle because we've been
selling ebooks for 10 years and you have
needed an electron microscope to find
the sales
and so you know three years ago we said
look what we need to do is create a
perfect integrated streamlined customer
experience all the way through though
we'll build the device we'll build the
back end servers will digitize the
content ourselves if we need to whatever
it takes we're going to build a great
customer experience and we can get that
thing started and if other you know if
we can get you know other devices on you
know to to also be able to buy Kindle
books through other devices that's great
you know people it'll be a different
experience I mean the form factors
matter right I mean you know I've read
books on my blackberry it's doable I
don't recommend it you know it's a it's
a it's it's in a pinch
yeah it's something you could do I did
it just as an experiment for myself you
know I'm sure wanting to know it would
be like but I don't I don't think that's
what most people want to do I think you
know and there are you know I like
having a cell phone camera I like having
a little tiny camera on my cell phone
it's very convenient but I you you know
but I still like having a real camera
and so if reading is important to you
and there are a lot of people in this
world to whom reading is important this
light understands that and it it's gonna
be worth it to you to have a
purpose-built reading device that's
perfect for reading just like I love
having in fact I have a I have a camera
on my cell phone I have a little you
know compact camera purpose-built camera
and I have an SLR camera because I have
different needs for cameras and I think
that's gonna be I think reading is like
that - you know Matt Matt well I want to
read occasionally on my blackberry or my
cell phone yeah maybe but mostly I want
to read short things they're a recipe
book for example would work on a
blackberry but not China not worn piece
so I mean in your you know when you
describe your founding vision of Amazon
recognizing that there was an
underserved market place out there the
books that failed the economic test of
traditional retail and distribution
it was the obscure it was the orange it
was basically most book but not the bad
no this is the thing that people
sometimes conflate they think if a book
is as is obscure maybe there's something
wrong with it the people in this
audience won't think that but the but
you know the the mainstream person can
get confused about that and the reality
is it might just have a narrow audience
exactly I mean what we're learning
really in the last ten years the
Internet is that is that the the things
we would feel most passionately about
are off in the places where we differ
from everyone else is the it's the is
that it's the absolute defines as
individuals or almost almost always the
ways that we we deviate from the
mainstream that's right so so so what
you did is you created a marketplace to
have the room room for the little as
well as the big room for the narrow and
the niche and that and and and the focus
as well as for the mass and the broad
how do you think just we've kind of
standing back with your sort of cultural
anthropologist how do you think that has
changed the nature of book reading and
writing in America and in the last what
14 years I guess well I think the
friction reduction I mean if you look at
we we skew if you look at our sales
relative to traditional bookstores we
skew so strongly toward the tail so you
know you know we're gonna be doing you
know a lot of the volume and magneto
hydrodynamics volume too you know and
that in that's an important book if
you're studying magneto hydrodynamics
for most of us it's not a very important
book it just does it's not on our radar
and so providing access to people in a
convenient fast way to these kinds of
titles is I I think it's a very you know
valuable cultural mission
so the said the authors who wrote
magneto hydrodynamics vol 2 now gets a
larger readership doesn't maybe not
necessary shift the needle in terms of
his or her economic he thing is they're
getting the right
in the right leadership and the nd and
the write a book on Minoan script B you
may not expect that many people to read
it but you sure want the ones who want
to read it to be able to find it
Minoan scripts I'm just making a prayer
obscure thing I see that was good you
know what it is it's not rare enough I
was with you right through the magneto
hydrodynamics but the reader the readers
now that chemistry you find the right
readers you find that those readers are
more broadly distributed than the
distribution university bookstores for
instance so you know you touch more
readers who touch them the right way and
we and writers get a bigger audience
well in there are two pieces of this or
at least two pieces right one is that
the you don't have shelf space
constraints so you can put you know very
we can literally have millions of titles
under our own roof in big fulfillment
centers and you know you just can't do
in expensive retail real estate where
you have to have a high traffic area for
a traditional bookstore and the second
thing is you can provide tools to help
people find those things so you know you
come on to Amazon and you can search
once you find one thing that looks
interesting to you we have a different
kind of tool called
you know customers who bought this also
bought this it helps you wind your way
through the store and find things that
are really relevant to your interests no
matter how narrow those are and and that
kind of tool customers who bought this
also bought that is we call it's a class
of things we call discovery tools or
serendipity tools and what we're trying
to do is accelerate discovery and
accelerate serendipity because if you
just had a huge warehouse with millions
of titles in it and a no good way to
access or find those the connections
between those two zones and in Kindle
has the opportunity to take that to the
next level there's literally no shelf
space constraints literally nothing ever
goes out of print now everything you
know Amazon Prime can get it to you for
free in two days but Kenton
to you for free in 60 seconds it's it's
a step function change do you think it's
possible to say 2 2 2 2 2 look at the
the trend lines in the in the in the
book industry numbers of books you know
you know the range of readerships ages
demographics whatever and point to the
Amazon effect in the last 10 years I
don't know I it's pretty I think in
terms of demographics it's pretty broad
the volumes of books are written today
that wouldn't have been written we're
not for this infinite infinite
marketplace I suspect so but I can't I
can't prove it one of the most profound
things is probably something you never
intended but like taking a used book
market and making it a liquid market one
click away etc he basically rendered out
of print obsolete
yes books don't really from a consumer
perspective you usually get a an out
print used copy it is there they're
equally available yes how do you think
that has changed has changed the
industry and either way either coming at
it from a kind of a you know a book
selling perspective or reading
perspective well I think you know this
is one of those things when we first did
it people were very unhappy with us in
the in the publishing industry and
because the you know we're putting these
used books next to the new ones and you
know we're very simple-minded about
things like that
and we if it's if we think it's a good
customer experience our belief is long
term it will be very good for the whole
ecosystem and I think that has proven
out with used books I think it has made
it easier for you know a lot of people
who are much more willing to try an
author if they can pay four dollars to
try the author and you know the the
studies we've done have not demonstrated
any cannibalization at all we see more
and more readership it's similar to the
the kindle effect that i showed where
we're seeing you know people buy just as
many physical books post kindle purchase
as they did pre kindle and yet they buy
kindle books too I was surprised but
that can you explain it I think it's
just that they're easier to buy anything
that you when you reduce
by more physical books buying him but
they're buying the same number of
physical books behind the same number of
physical books that they always bought
and then plus they buy Kindle books and
the total all together is 2.6 times what
they bought in the pre Kindle purchase
period and that lack of cannibalization
surprised you I at this stage it doesn't
surprise me too much but you know
because we've seen it before with things
like use books I I think I'm a little
surprised at how many Kindle books
they're mine hmm
I'm not really surprised that they
continue to buy physical books waste it
by the way we had it's a subset of
Kindle owners we see very strong pattern
it's some of the people the audience may
do this I do it occasionally too is they
buy both so they want the electronic
book and they buy the print book I think
the cost keeps you know more people
would do that if the cost was not
prohibitive but you know there are
certain customers for whom that's a good
they want the paper book maybe that's
gonna go on their shelf yeah and then
they want the convenience of being able
to take it on the airplane or whatever
if they're traveling around or whatever
purpose have it on the Kindle speaking
of the cost to answer the obvious
question in the audience that that
individual who bought the 1,700 books I
checked with your staff it's not
actually Jeff it's also not my mom it's
not yet it's obviously a very good
customer whoever you are thank you you
mentioned the controversy and and you
know putting a consumer first in the
controversy that the used book market
caused there's one there's one minor
controversy at the moment maybe major
one about about said the print on demand
service and it's a very similar
situation where you know well from you
know when you make changes mm-hmm when
you try to improve something you're
gonna pioneer something you are gonna
create some controversy from time to
time and you have to be willing to be
misunderstood you have to be sure you're
what you're doing is that you feel good
about it and if you don't you can go
back and course-correct but if you're if
you're simple-minded about the customer
experience that usually keeps you on the
right side of that line
and you know the AU's book is a great
example but even small things that we
have done that I think later people
accept and actually find helpful have
initially caused controversy the I can
tell you one of the first ones we have
lots of scar tissue on this one of the
first ones and you know we were a tiny
company it was a big deal for us at the
time was that there was a lot of
hostility about negative customer
reviews customer reviews are accepted
now they're very commonplace but they
are you know there was a time when it
seemed very bad to certain people that
we would allow negative customer we got
one letter and says you don't understand
your business you make money when you
sell things please take down these
negative reviews and you know our point
of view is we make money when we help
people make purchase decisions it's a
different it's a different viewpoint and
and I think I'm I'm sure even though I
can't I probably couldn't prove it but I
am I have a absolute confidence that
customer reviews including negative
reviews increase book sales because they
help people make purchase decisions and
if you can have the print-on-demand I
mean as many people in this room will
know already what that technology is but
modern print on demand printers can
print a complete book print and bind a
complete book in two hours and you know
we have in our own fulfillment centers
we have millions of traditionally
printed books you know pre-printed in
there on shelves and in pallets in
cartons they're ready to be shipped out
to customers and we have Amazon Prime
customers and others in the the
timelines on on latency for shipping
these books are very short and
transportation cost is critically
important to us if somebody orders two
books and most orders are for more than
two units you know it's not so just so
you know it's a scenario took more than
oh no not the same book into two books
but just two two units
at the same sometimes it is but but it's
very very common for people to buy two
things and it basically costs us twice
as much to transport two books if we
have to send them in two separate boxes
as it does if we can marry them together
and so with things like Amazon Prime
where we make two-day shipping free and
things like Super Saver Shipping where
we make shipping free if you order $25
and that $25 this often gets people to
order two items well if we can print the
book in our own fulfillment center which
we're now set up to do because we've
installed these printers in our
fulfillment centers now you know if you
order two things and one of them is a
print on demand book since very few
books you know kind of in a demand sense
rpoud ebooks print on demand books most
books are still traditional books that
we saw you probably ordered a
traditional book and a print on demand
book if you ordered a print on demand
book so we want to marry those two
things in one box and we can save a lot
of money by doing that we can get the
product to customers faster we can pass
on the savings to customers in the form
of lower prices and that's a great
customer experience but it does require
that the book be printed if it's a PID
book in our fulfillment center and some
people you know that's gonna make some
people unhappy well the controversy a
presumably is that is that if they use
your print on demand service it gets
preferential access preferential for
somebody a placement and and possibly
pricing if you use somebody else's it is
it is disadvantaged well you know we
have to negotiate terms with every
vendor 101 which is what we do but you
know it makes a lot of sense system-wide
mmm-hmm system-wide it does not make
sense to print a p OD book now anywhere
but in our fulfillment center why
because we want to be able to marry the
two books in one box okay if you make it
listen if you just to make connect the
dots because I said you know if you
print it somewhere else to get them into
a single box you've got a cross ship
that book to us which is going to be a
delay
we're gonna ship it to you tomorrow
instead of today and that's a bad
customer experience
could you give customers the choice no
I'd rather I'd rather just push through
and do the right thing for customers and
you know and I you have to have a
willingness to be misunderstood if
you're gonna pioneer you have to
I'm sure there's there's people in the
audience II would like to drill down
this forever but by the way we're not
saying that we want you there are many
ways to store books in our fulfillment
centers so it's not you know they're all
it well-meaning people misunderstand you
sometimes but also there are often
sometimes people with vested interests
who'd have a reason to misunderstand you
understood we hate we've got about about
about maybe six or seven minutes left to
go and I want to cover you know there's
a lot of other things we could talk
about we haven't even gotten to your
space program yet but the one thing and
this is this is I I think this is um I
think it's a really big deal from my
perspective you know covering the broad
world of Technology and I hope it's
gonna be relevant and we can make it
relevant to this audience but you're
easy to you're easy to probe lastic
compute class to compute cloud and the
s3 storage equivalently I'm guessing
that people in this room do not know
would you raise your hand if you know
what the Elastic Compute cloud is okay
so more than I would have guessed
I'm minority well I but I would say that
you know this is this is one of these
moments where you're sort of you know in
the in the broad sphere of technology
this is a game-changer this is the you
know in my world this is this is the
most interesting thing Amazon is doing
and maybe you could talk a little bit
about how you got into this sort of you
know competing with Google and Internet
infrastructure and why it makes sense
for you as a business and what the
opportunity might be for something well
for the 95 percent of people who did not
raise their hand
the Elastic Compute cloud is a it's
basically given letting any software
engineer any developer any company the
opportunity to buy compute basically buy
time on servers buy the drink so instead
of building a data center and filling it
with servers
you can pay 10 cents per hour per server
and so we transform what would normally
be a very large fixed cost into a
variable cost and you can run your
applications on servers inside Amazon's
data centers we started working on this
for years ago it now goes by many
different names
people call it grid computing which is a
reference to the electric power grid
they call it utility computing which is
another reference selector power grid I
have a personal story about this which
really brought it home from you just a
few months ago I was in Luxembourg and
the I was at a 300 year old brewery and
they gave me a tour and the brewery had
a hundred years ago they had generate
their own electric power so in the
museum they had this huge electric power
generator and you know the point is
generating your own electric power
didn't make your beer taste any better
and so as soon as the electric grid
became available in Luxembourg they
stopped making their own power and they
relied on the electric grid and for most
people it doesn't make sense to generate
your own electric power and I believe we
live in a very temporary multi decade
period where people are doing the
equivalent of generating their own
electric power by building their own
data centers it doesn't make sense for
most companies to have their own data
stores and now we have the internet and
all this connectivity your data center
doesn't have to be close to you and so
you can have these bigger centralized
data centers width which is what the
Elastic Compute cloud is and you can buy
capacity on-demand give up capacity on
demand that way you have one big pool of
capacity it's very exciting you know we
started this four years ago we were
really doing it initially for ourselves
as we were building the set of they're
called api's application programming
interfaces as we're building the set of
API is we realized if we did a little
extra work we could externalize those
api's and Saum to others
and so we've started a whole new
business which focuses on a developer
customer set and that has been very
successful
you know I rarely run into a startup
company today that's not using Amazon
Web Services Elastic Compute cloud we
have some other services too simple
storage service simple queueing service
they're all very there is a very
technical set of service offerings
targeted at software engineers and now
we're starting to see big enterprise
customers use our cloud computing as
well so it's it's it's interesting any
particular examples from the publishing
industry well the New York Times is used
our web services used Amazon Web
Services to put the hundred years of New
York Times archives on the web so it was
you know I don't know a terabyte plus of
scanned data they used our servers to do
all of the OCR and on that data and the
image compression and and then and also
use it to do the searching and the
indexing and so on and they're able to
put up with about any fixed cost of
building out a datacenter to do that job
so we just have a few minutes I guess I
really have a choice between geeking out
with you over over space or get taking
questions from the audience well I I can
tell you a little bit about space we
don't like happy to take all these
questions but listen well so first of
all you know you don't choose your
passions your passions choose you and
since I was five years old I have been
passionate about space and the I never
thought I'd actually have the chance to
do anything about it but Amazon has
certainly been a lottery ticket and by
the way that is how I think about it
it's you know to gut the startup company
that Amazon was 14 years ago it was me
and three other people and you have no
idea how much planetary alignment had to
occur for Amazon so you know even
mistakes we made just by good luck
turned out to be the right decisions at
the time so that but what it has allowed
me to do is to start this company called
Blue Origin and Blue Origin
is his building a suborbital space
vehicle and it's gonna carry astronauts
carry passengers up into suborbital
space suborbital space was like what
Alan Shepard did and so you don't go all
the way into orbit going all the way
into orbit is probably 20 times harder
than suborbital space I'm sure you all
remember your high school physics but
energy goes with velocity squared and
you got to go really fast to get into
orbit and so the amount of energy you
need to get into orbit is really high
and then if you ever want to come back
you have to get rid of all that energy
which means you have to re-enter the
Earth's atmosphere and you set all that
energy by decelerating through the
friction with the atmosphere which by
the way makes your space capsule quite
hot and so that's a very difficult
technical problem we're doing something
much simpler which as a first step is to
you go up into space you go up 100
kilometers
you'll be up for about 3 minutes or so
and then you come down the unusual thing
about our you'll come down separately
but the the propulsion module the thing
that takes you up is a vertical landing
rocket so it's like a Buck Rogers rocket
takes off on its tail like a normal
rocket but it's reusable and it comes
back and it lands under rocket power on
its tail at very gently and that's the
plan and we have built our first
development vehicle which we flew a year
or so ago
multiple times we're working on our
second development vehicle now there
will be at least one more development
vehicle after that and then we will
hopefully have a commercial vehicle but
there may be more developing the
vehicles we don't know it's not the kind
of thing it operates on a different time
scale from internet businesses which you
know I think is very appropriate because
you know we're going to put people in
this vehicle I'm going to go
myself I'm a physical coward so it has
to be very safe and you know I think
it's really interesting and our motto at
Blue Origin is greed Atum ferocity which
means step by step ferociously and what
we want to do is first do this
suborbital vehicle and then we'll do you
know a series of vehicles and ultimately
the long term goal is to be part of an
industry that helps humanity get into
space and I think that would be really
cool but it's probably much more
relevant in this to talk about reading
note let's have a question starting over
here that will switch back and forth or
the gentlemen the white shirt here yes
the question is will there be PDF files
on Kindle and the answer is we worked
our tails off a kid personal Kindle does
support PDF files we don't brag about it
because they only work about 80 percent
of the time so you can email a word doc
and that works almost every time to your
Kindle you can email PDF and that will
work about 80% of the time it's an
unbelievably hard technical problem
because PDFs were not designed to flow
so when you change that if the PDF is
laid out for you know eight and a half
by eleven which many PDFs are then by
the time you drink it to the Kindle
screen size it's unreadable
and if you try to reflow it which is
what we do it's you know it works
sometimes so and if it has any fancy
formatting that's what it fails so we
are and that is something we would
really love to nail and we haven't
figured out how to do it but you should
try it I mean go ahead and email PDFs to
your Kindle you'll find it usually works
especially if they're simple PDFs it'll
work very well
the woman in front and then then we'll
bounce to the one back row yeah yes yeah
the question for those of you who
couldn't hear it is you know can you
take quark files we have a hole if you
go to that web address we have a whole
series of ways for you to submit content
to us and get it in Kindle and it's
quite sync wish to make a big Kindle to
work great for cookbooks and or that
doesn't require Reef lowing of the
people for PDFs it doesn't and I think
you know the answer that question I
don't know when or if we would do such a
thing but technically it's certainly
possible and I actually am a I'm a bit
of a cookbook collector and you know I'm
not much of a cook but I attempt it my
hosting impulse comes out and I don't
like to cook so I would love to see
cookbooks do better you know be it's
true that the format of Kindle doesn't
work that well for certain kinds of
highly structured pages it works great
for things that are mostly text and so
we've got our work cut out for us you
know we need to make this thing better
over time we will there'll be a second
version and a third version a tenth
version and you know we'll make it great
but you'll have to bear with us let's
make them quick questions please that's
dumb in here okay yeah actually that's
one of the areas that we're very focused
on and it is and it's similar to the
cookbook question in a way because the
current Kindle doesn't support most
textbooks that well a lot of textbooks
have diagrams
I mean diagrams if they're done for the
Kindle are beautiful but a textbook
usually requires a lot more kind of hand
lay-up to get it perfect for the Kindle
than many other kinds of books the
typical book we can mostly reflow and in
a very you know 95% automated way make a
beautiful
Kindle version of that book but if
something has multiple columns and you
know charts and graphs or if it has a
lot of color then you have to really go
in and say okay how would I do this
illustration if I don't have color and
you can't often you can't just you know
Kindle has four shades of gray so you
know there you have to you have to use
some ingenuity to redo those
illustrations so but the answer to your
question is yeah that's a big focus area
for us both in terms of you know
evolving the product over time and
working with textbook publishers because
I do think it's a fantastic tool for
education pretty evident just for one
more question
leave refund please yes or no and
raffling yes or no well if you can think
of a quick way to do a raffle I'd be
happy to do that send you a Kindle if
you and just make sure you come up
afterwards and it what was the first
question audiobook yes it does it has
speakers built-in it has audiobook
capability you can download audible
books you cannot download our audiobooks
wirelessly you have to do them over the
USB cable so you have to first download
them to your computer and then download
them from the computer kind of the
old-fashioned way the reason for that is
that the audio books are very bulky
they're big files but Kindle plays audio
books very nicely thank you not yet the
question is the UK and we are working on
global versions of the device but I
can't be any more specific than that
thank you you guys thank you please do
anything Jeff Bezos and please come find
me
Jeff Bezos is founder and CEO of
amazon.com Chris Anderson is the
editor-in-chief of Wired magazine he's
the author of the longtail why the
future of business is selling less of
more David Hilliard a founding member of
the Black Panther Party